the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's get started I hope everybody
had a great long weekend so I'm teaching
today and today we're gonna be talking
about transactions so just to recap
where we've been so far
taja's sort of explained signatures in
Bitcoin in particular RSA and ECDSA and
told us a little bit about Merkle trees
and so these are some of the underlying
primitives that we need to know about in
order to understand how most of the
block chains today are constructed okay
so we spent a bit of time talking about
the underlying primitives now let's
start to put them together a little bit
and to understand what goes into a
blockchain so if you recall this is a
slide that had just shown before and I'm
really sorry about this quadrant but I
don't know I don't think I could control
this individually so we'll definitely
post the slides of course but let me
know if something is really confusing
just raise your hand so this is
something that you guys have seen before
and it's like a very sort of rough
approximation of a hash chain okay so
what we have here is we have this
doesn't actually show the previous but
what we have here is we have some
message we have an on such that when you
hash these three things together you get
this hash value which has a certain
number of leading zeros at the beginning
in this case it's two leading zeros and
when we construct the next block we
point to implicitly point to this
previous block by including that hash
inside of this when we produce this hash
so note that there isn't actually a
physical pointer or memory address
pointer type thing connecting these two
things together and note that this block
does not actually contain the hash of
itself but we are sort of implicitly
pointing to this by including the hash
of this block in the following block
okay and so on over here again this is a
different message at different knots and
it includes the hash of this block
instead of the one before and by
including the hash of this block it's
also implicitly including the hash of
this block because that's right here and
what we're gonna see is that if you
change anything about the previous
blocks in the blockchain for example if
you changed this message then you know
you're going to need to change the knots
in order to get the hash to compute
right it's gonna be a different hash and
that change is gonna trickle down
through the entire blockchain and so
that's what makes these things what we
call tamper proof the fact that there
are these hashes these hashes are
collision collision resistant and so
it's very difficult you can't really
compute something out you can't change
what's in the past without having it
reflected in the future so now let's go
into a little bit more detail about
exactly what this message thing is okay
we've talked about the previous hash
pointers we've talked about the nonce
we've talked about proof of work but
what actually goes inside of a block
well we have this general we've kind of
been alluding to it but what goes inside
a block are transactions we're trying to
build a payment system here so what do
we need to have in a transaction what
should a transaction look like yes okay
inputs and outputs maybe even like a
higher level here like semantically what
do we want in a transaction yep okay a
sender a receiver an amount anybody else
okay an ID some way of referencing it
anybody else
yep
a proof that it's a legit transaction
right so um exactly so what we need is
those things that you guys just said we
need to know the amount how much of this
coin we're transferring we need to know
where it's coming from and in particular
we need an authorization of some sort
that that user actually authorized the
spend and we need who were paying and so
unfortunately this is in the dark part
but this is sort of like you know a
little rough sketch of a transaction and
we have Alice who's spending $5 to Bob
and we have this authorization here
okay and this authorization given we
just learned about signatures signatures
are a great way to do authorization
because it's something that only Alice
can produce right so um I don't know if
you can see this but there question
marks here so what should Alice sign to
show that she authorized this
transaction what do you think would be a
good thing what is a good message for
her to sign for her to indicate her
authority her her desire to produce this
transaction and spend her funds her
private key she should sign her private
key okay the whole transaction okay so
let's talk about signing the private key
let's say that she did sign her private
key okay the problem with a signature is
that in order to tell if the signatures
valid you need the thing that you signed
so she would have to include her private
key which would then share her private
key with everyone which isn't really a
good way for her to use her public and
private key she couldn't certainly sign
the transaction and the nice thing about
signing the transaction this is all blue
indicating that she's signing it is that
she's signing all three of these things
as well right she's saying I want to pay
Bob I want to pay Bob five dollars now
what's a problem with signing the
transaction yes
so that is an excellent point you could
keep using it if you were Bob and we'll
get into that a little bit later but
another problem here is the way that
I've shown it right now she's signing
the signature the signature is kind of
part of the transaction and so you want
to make sure that you're you're not you
know when you sign a transaction you're
signing everything but the signature
right because you can't produce the
signature you can't sign the signature
without knowing what the signature is it
would be like a whole new type of proof
of work on the transaction so I don't
know if you can see this but this says
transaction - signature and in fact you
know we can even make that a little bit
easier by turning that into a hash of
the transaction not including the
signature because that sort of brings a
message down to a smaller thing and from
what we know about hash functions you
can't really given given a message and a
hash of that message it's difficult to
produce another message that would hash
to the same thing so this hash serves as
kind of an identifier for the
transaction as a whole in fact Bitcoin
uses the hash of this as the transaction
ID so this is how we refer to
transactions and it's a nice small thing
to sign which indicates Alice's intent
to spend her funds so one thing that I
kind of want to go into a little bit is
that there's a couple different ways for
thinking about transactions and what
transactions actually look like and how
they're stored and how we sort of
specify coins and to the most natural
model to me anyway not to everybody
perhaps is what I call the account based
model so it's kind of like what we were
doing before when we saw the banks and
we were talking about banks keeping
track of how many how much funds people
have and this is sort of how you and I
might think of our own bank accounts I
think in my bank account as having a
certain amount of funds in it right and
so in the account based model users have
certain amounts or balances associated
with their with their user names and
when a transaction comes in like Alice
wants to give five dollars to Bob then
what might happen is that the the nodes
and the network which are all
maintaining sort of an in a unified way
this balance sheet will end up saying
okay Alice had ten and Bob had zero
Alice wants to give $5 to Bob let's
subtract five from Alice's account and
give it to Bob and so what the nodes
would do here to see if this transaction
was valid would be they would check the
signature to make sure that Alice
actually authorized this transaction and
they would also make sure that Alice had
the funds to spend and in the account
based model the way that you check to
see if Alice has the funds to spend is
you literally look at her balance and
you look at the amount she wants to
spend and you make sure that if she
spends that amount the balance won't go
below zero so this is actually the model
that aetherium uses it's not the model
that Bitcoin uses so just sort of to
summarize you store a list of accounts
and balances a transaction is valid if
there's a balance in the account and
then when a transaction is processed you
debit the sender and credit the receiver
so very straightforward now so like I
said this is the way that etherium works
and it's it's a little bit more natural
I think to think about but this is not
the way Bitcoin works actually Bitcoin
has a very different model of coins and
of transactions and I I think the you
know when I was learning about how
Bitcoin worked and how aetherium worked
I found bitcoins model a little bit
unnatural until I went through this
exercise of thinking about something
called replay attacks and this is what
Isan mentioned earlier right which is
when you have this transaction and you
know you you send it to the network and
the network processes the transaction
and debits alice and credits Bob what is
to prevent you know a malicious agent
from noticing that transaction and
rebroadcasting it again to the network
so basically repeatedly debiting alice
until until she doesn't have any funds
left so can you guys think of a way to
maybe get around this what would you do
how would you how would you prevent this
replay attack yes
so one thing is adding a time sure time
is a little bit tricky because of the
nature of the system maybe you know but
but a time is like a pretty good idea a
unique number of some kind certainly
would help because that way if you saw a
transaction with the same unique nut
with the same number then you'd know
okay this transaction has been seen
before this is a repeat this is a
rebroadcast this is not something I
should process so if you actually does
something like this there is sort of
this like this number included in every
transaction but the tricky part about
the way that aetherium does this and
we're gonna learn more about aetherium
later on in the course we're gonna have
a guest lecturer come in and teach us
about that is that it requires you to
keep track of all of the numbers you've
seen and you have to do this per user
and so all the nodes in the network have
to keep track of all of the nonces that
they've seen per user and so you know if
a user uses aetherium ones and then goes
away all of the nodes have to keep that
state forever essentially just in case
you know someone comes back and
rebroadcasts another transaction so um a
Bitcoin like I said and I keep saying
does something and there's nothing wrong
with this with this model we'll sort of
compare and contrast like I said it's
what aetherium uses but I think that
this was part of the motivation for why
Bitcoin was designed the way that it was
and so Bickman uses this idea called
unspent transaction outputs so you'll
notice like over here we don't have any
notion of a coin per se you know they're
just amounts and amounts are debited and
credited and if Alice spends two Bob and
Alice spends - Carol and they come in
different orders either one could happen
first you know there's no notion of like
Carol gets these coins and Bob gets
these coins but Bitcoin is a little bit
different all coins are not the same and
when you're spending you don't just
include an amount you refer back to the
specific coin that you are spending okay
so you actually have to refer to
coin in order to spend it and this is
the really weird part
coins are created or destroyed consumed
and and then new coins are created every
transaction okay so whenever you spend
your Bitcoin you have to spend it in its
entirety that bitcoin is then destroyed
and new coins are created and there's a
rule in the entire system that a coin
can only be spent once so let's go into
exact we'll go into exactly what that
looks like in a transaction but I want
to know if there are any questions about
that first about that idea yes yeah
that's a great question so the question
is aren't coins fungible so first of all
coins aren't fungible actually they they
they're very specific you can you can
like see a coin but you can like the
question about can you know what happens
if you want to only want to spend part
of a coin is a great question and we'll
see how you do that in in the way that
the transaction is constructed but the
short answer is if you want to spend
part of a coin you have to spend the
whole coin spend the part that you want
to someone else and then spend the rest
of it back to yourself creating a new
coin in the process yes whoever you say
should own the new ones when you're when
so the transaction consumes coins and
creates new ones as payment and as the
creator of that transaction is the
spender I will decide who should get the
new coins and I'll show you details of
this in a moment
no not exactly full balance in the
account so let's uh let's let's go a
little bit further to look at what's
happening here because Bitcoin doesn't
actually keep track of balances so let's
take a look at what a transaction
actually looks like okay so a
transaction has many different parts but
we're gonna focus on two parts which is
the inputs and the outputs and here I'm
showing a transaction with one input and
one output okay
now an input actually refers back to
another transactions output so let's
assume and we'll get into how this is
done later but let's assume that there
are coins in the system okay let's just
assume that some coins have been created
out of nowhere let's say in particular
that maybe 12.5 coins have been created
out of nowhere and so there's a
transaction that outputs 12.5 coins to
Alice and Alice wants to spend those
coins and so Alice would create a new
transaction that points back to the
transaction where she received those
coins and the way that she points back
to that is using the transaction ID of
the previous transaction which you
remember she's the hash the index
meaning which output of the previous
transaction she's intending to spend and
something called a script sig which is
her authorization to spend that output
so this is how alice refers back to the
output she wants to spend and when I say
coin I'm referring to outputs
okay so outputs can be for different
amounts output you know you could create
an output you could spend 12.5 coins and
create many different outputs of many
different amounts and send them to
different people if you wanted to so
this is the format of a transaction
there's an input which points back to a
previous transactions output that you're
intending to spend and then the way that
you spend it you're consuming that
output essentially by pointing back to
it with this input the way that you
spend it is by producing a new output
okay and again this transaction just
doesn't want input
one output it could have many and the
output that you produce has something
called a script pub key what the script
pub key is the script pump key is a way
of specifying the conditions under which
this output can be redeemed so in its
simplest sense you might have the script
cig merely be a signature just alice's
signature saying i have the right to
spend this and if alice is spending too
bob then maybe the script pub key would
actually just be Bob's public key and
the implied meaning there would be
anyone who could produce a signature of
the corresponding private key with that
public key could then spend this output
one thing is that these two things
together the previous transaction ID and
the index serves to uniquely identify an
output so these two things uniquely
identify some money to spend okay and
the value that's specified in the output
is actually specified in something
called satoshis and there are 10 to the
8th satoshis in one Bitcoin so the value
doesn't have any decimal places in it it
is always an integer an output is what
I'm referring to when I say the word
coin so questions on this sort of
general set up yes
[Music]
sure um okay the index is I remember how
I said there could be multiple outputs
the index simply refers to which output
in the previous transaction you're
talking about was there a question back
there
[Music]
sure yes we'll get to that in a moment
actually but maybe I could just draw one
on the board so so you could certainly
have a transaction that has multiple
outputs okay
and so this input here would refer back
to some previous transactions outputs
and let's say that this was for example
20 Bitcoin okay then
this needs to consume 20 Bitcoin and it
can spread that 20 Bitcoin out in any
way that it wants and there's some
details here that we're gonna get to in
a moment
but basically you have that 20 here you
could send five here ten here five here
and each of these outputs would have its
own script pub key its own rules for how
to redeem it and each output has its own
amount yep that's a good question so um
if we if you go back to the slide where
I sort of was showing this is where the
name chain comes from here so what we're
talking about right now is what goes
inside each block and what goes inside
each block are transactions so for the
moment you can pretend like each block
only has one transaction in it but a
block can contain a set of transactions
but the chain part comes from how we
actually chained these blocks of
transactions together
okay so let's talk about script zigs and
script pub keys a little bit more so
script pub keys like I said are in the
outputs and you can think of them as
predicates so script pub keys specify a
predicate on how someone can redeem this
output okay so remember transaction can
have multiple inputs multiple outputs
each output has its own script pub key
script SIG's
which are in the inputs help satisfy the
predicate that's specified in the script
pub key so we would have a script pump
key here and we would have a script sig
here and this script sig if this is a
valid transaction would explain how to
satisfy the script pub key so the script
pub key would set up a predicate on the
output the most common predicate is
produce a signature and a public key
that satisfies this hash and the script
sig would provide the information
necessary to satisfy that predicate so
what does it mean to have money in this
system what does it mean to be able to
spend money what does it mean for Alice
to be able to transfer money to Bob it
means Alice know some information that
allows her to produce a satisfying
script sig for some outputs out there
that's what having money means it's not
an account balance so questions on that
because it's a little non-intuitive but
the important thing to note here is the
nodes in the Bitcoin network are not
keeping track of how much money you have
it's your job to keep track of how much
money you have or a wallets job and
we'll talk more about wallets later and
the way that you do that is by knowing
how many outputs there are out there
that you can actually
that you have the knowledge to redeem
like I said a transaction can have
multiple inputs and multiple outputs and
each input comes with its own script sig
and each output comes with its own
script pub key so it's not that there's
one script sig in one script pub key for
the entire transaction a transaction can
actually spend multiple different
outputs and produce multiple different
new outputs and these outputs could have
nothing to do with each other here this
input might point to a previous output
that Alice knows how to spend and this
input might point to a previous output
the Carol knows how to spend and you can
actually combine both of those into the
same transaction assuming you can
produce a transaction with the right
script 6 now Alice and Carol might have
to talk to each other in order to
produce this transaction because it's
going to need both signatures but they
could do it great question so you know
what prevents people from shuffling
around the inputs and the outputs well
part of it is because this is serialized
into a transaction and that transaction
is hashed and then these signatures are
on that transaction hash remember we saw
that from a few slides before so if you
were to flip around the order or if you
were to trying to change any bits in
here and change the pub key you would
end up changing the hash of the
transaction and this signature would no
longer be valid and something also
that's important to note only valid
transactions get accepted to the
blockchain so all of the nodes are
checking to make sure that the script
pub keys and these scripts IG's work out
and I'll show you the rules that they're
checking in just a moment
and so it's it's if anything doesn't
match if this signature is not a valid
script sig for whatever output it's
pointing to this is an invalid
transaction no one will accept it in
fact most nodes won't even pass it
around and it will not get into the
blockchain or if it does get into the
blockchain all of the nodes were
following the rules of the network will
ignore it because if a transaction is
invalid it means the entire block is
invalid
and it means any chain building off that
block is also invalid so nodes that are
following the rules of the network which
are these should be valid will not
listen to that and will completely
ignore that entire chain so here's
another visual of sort of what it looks
like to have and this is not what the
blockchain looks like I want to be clear
the blockchain is just a set of blocks
pointing to previous blocks what we have
here is more sort of like the logical
representation of what a transaction
looks like so you have a transaction
right here and you have two inputs in
this transaction and the first one is
pointing to the second output of this
previous transaction that happened over
here so this transaction has a hash and
you know maybe this is the hash of the
entire transaction and so in order to
spend that output over there you specify
the hash you specify the index so 0 1 2
you specify this index right here and
you provide a script sig that will
validate according to whatever the
script pub key is for that output so
note here this transaction doesn't care
what those outputs are at all it's not
using those it's not looking at those
someone else might spend those someone
else might not spend those it's just
spending this one right here and in the
act of spending this one right here it
doesn't make those other ones invalid in
the simplest form those could still be
spent by someone else so outputs are
consumed separately so here it's
pointing to a different transaction the
transaction with this hash and so it
specifies the transaction ID and then it
specifies which output in that
transaction it's spending in this case
it's the third one so it has index two
and it provides a satisfying script sig
for this output which might be total it
probably is totally different than the
satisfying script sig for that output so
this is what this transaction has to
specify in order to spend those outputs
and it can produce whatever new outputs
it wants to produce under certain rules
not whole box so actually points to
something else um this box what do you
mean when you say points - this is
something that will be inside of the
blockchain inside of a block in the
blockchain so this doesn't actually
point to anything it contains hashes
like literally it just contains these
bytes these hashes of the transactions
that it's spending and those are kind of
like a pointer in a sense but when it
comes to the entire blockchain this is
one part of one block yeah I know can
you guys see this at all can you still
see that or no okay good okay great yeah
you had your hand up
that was sort of more like an idealized
transaction so this is what a
transaction actually looks like the
transaction but when you sign the
transaction you don't sign the script
six because the script says include the
signature of the transaction and it's
important to note the scripts tag
includes the signature of the
transaction as a whole not just this
part of it yes great question so um you
know okay I said that there's this rule
that outputs are supposed to only be
consumed once but I can definitely
produce another transaction which points
back to that output I could send it to
the network and what would happen is the
nodes in the network assuming they're
following consensus rules would note
that this had already been spent so if
this is already if they've already seen
a transaction a valid transaction that
consumes an output they will not accept
another transaction that tries to spend
the same output that's what's known as a
double spend and so all the nodes in the
network together are maintaining this
rule great question yes you know this
seems kind of annoying right like you
you see this transaction and okay
there's some random bytes in here and
some you know a signature and how am I
supposed to figure out what this goes to
right how am I supposed to figure out
you know whether this is a valid
transaction whether it's been spent or
not and the answer is that every single
node is maintaining a lot of data
structures in order to make this faster
and in fact they're maintaining a data
structure called the outs the UT exocet
and I'll tell you a little bit about the
UT Exocet in a minute but really the
I'll tell you how its created in a
moment yes
sure um so I'm not gonna go into how a
block is how what a block is composed of
I'm not gonna go into help what a block
is composed of but we will tomorrow yes
yes I I'm sorry could you say yes yes
there's a different script say for each
input there's a different script sig for
each input but that's cryptic signs most
of the transaction so the scripts say
there's a different one because the
because different outputs could have
different satisfying conditions but the
script sig has to sign a message right
or has to produce something actually
we're gonna go into a few specific
script SIG's and I think it'll be a lot
clearer exactly what this is because
it's not clear right now what goes in
the script so you're in the script punky
so this is sort of like a logical
representation of what a transaction
looks like it refers to the previous
transaction that it's spending from and
the important things to note here are
you can spend you don't have to spend
all of the outputs in a transaction you
can just spend one but you must consume
that output entirely and produce when
you produce your new outputs and so this
is what's actually like this is the JSON
representation of a transaction in
Bitcoin okay and so this is probably
pretty hard to read and I don't think
it's worth it to try to look at
everything in great detail but when we
have the slides up you can take a look
at this and this is literally what goes
inside a transaction and there are a few
fields that I'm not talking about here
one is the version and another is the
lock time and I think when we talk these
scripts the script Punkie and scripts it
can actually get quite interesting and
quite complex that's what makes
bitcoins so cool and I think when we get
into that discussion about all the
different things that can go into that
then we'll talk a little bit more about
what and lock time is or lock time is
but the the short answer is the lock
time tells you at what point in time
this transaction is valid so until that
lot of time happens the transaction is
not valid and can't be included in the
blockchain so this transaction is a lot
of time of zero meaning it's valid
immediately and can be included in the
blockchain so here this has one input
the input has the transaction ID and the
index so that's zero so it's spending
the first output of whatever that
transaction is and it has some scripting
which is empty so and then this is the
output that it's producing its spending
49.99 bitcoins from that previous output
output and it's spending it to a new
output and these are the rules for
redeeming with this new output let's
talk about consensus rules so I keep
using the word valid right this
transaction is valid this transactions
invalid and so there are these implicit
rules to Bitcoin which are defined by
the software which state what makes a
valid transaction or a valid block for
transactions specifically the sum of the
inputs has to be less than or equal to
the sum of the outputs so you can't
create money out of nowhere you have to
actually you can't spend more than
you're putting into a transaction and
why less than or equal to fees exactly
so the difference in the outputs and the
inputs is implicit and it's a fee that
essentially just goes to the miner the
person who produces the block there is
one exception to this rule it's a
transaction called the coinbase
transaction no relation to the company
it's not named after the company I think
the company is named after it but it's
the first transaction in a block and
it's the transaction that gives out the
block reward so the first transaction in
a block is the transit is special it
doesn't have any inputs or it does have
puts but they're meaningless and it
produces the block rewards so right now
the block reward is 12.5 bitcoins so
every time a block is produced every one
every time someone solves that
proof-of-work puzzle and produces a
block they include a transaction at the
very beginning that usually gives
themselves 12.5 Bitcoin plus whatever
fees are implicit in all of the trend in
as the sum of all of the transactions in
the block so this invariant must be
maintained except for the coinbase
transaction of which there's one in
every block and then this invariant must
also be maintained which oh yes sorry
the people creating the transaction
determine the fees so when I create a
transaction I'm specifying which outputs
I'm spending and putting them in my
inputs and I'm producing the outputs so
I could you know I just have to maintain
that invariant right so let's say that
I'm spending an import worth five
Bitcoin I could produce an output worth
five Bitcoin meaning that the fee is
zero it's very unlikely that my
transaction would get accepted into the
blockchain with a fee of zero it's
possible sure but if I'm not mining
myself why would a miner take my
transaction when they could take a
transaction that has a higher fee
associated with it and the fee is
implicit it's the difference between the
sum of the inputs and the sum of the
outputs any other questions at this
point the fee is okay the fee is
implicit so when you so in the inputs
you're consuming so let's let's use this
example right here okay so here we're
consuming this output which has 20
Bitcoin in it right so implicitly this
thing has 20 Bitcoin to spend alright
now before I had it set up as five ten
five right and so 20 needs to be greater
than or equal to 5 plus ten plus five
and it is great 20
greater than or equal to 20 what I could
do is I could change this number to a 4
and so what this means is notice that
this adds up to 19 now where did that
one Bitcoin go that one Bitcoin
implicitly goes to whoever produces the
block in which that contains this
transaction yeah you're right sorry that
should be greater than or equal to sorry
about that
so another invariant that needs to be
maintained is that this output has not
already been referenced in another
transaction in another valid transaction
and then as I alluded to a final
invariant is around the lock time so
let's go into an example of how this
actually works
this script sig and script pub key thing
so I haven't really gone into detail yet
about what this is I sort of implied
that this specified a key and the
specified a signature but what does this
actually look like and I mean I think
this is really really interesting
actually because Bitcoin lets you
specify lots of different script pub
keys and lots of different script SIG's
and so this gives you this kind of
flexibility so that you can program in
different kinds of conditions on what it
takes to redeem a transaction so we're
just going to talk about a couple very
simple ones because to get into sort of
more complex stuff we need to go really
deep into this word script so basically
the script pub key and the script sig
are composed of op codes so Bitcoin has
a little less than 200 op codes and you
write the coin scripts using these op
codes so let's talk about the most
common Bitcoin script which is paid a
pub key hash
so the idea here is you want to send
money to a public key so Alice has Bob's
public key and Alice wants to pay Bob
and so Alice wants to send money to
Bob's public key well the reason that
this is called pub key hash I thought
what keys are kind of big and there's
this nice you can kind of like make this
nice observation that you don't
necessarily have to put the whole public
key in the output you can put a hash of
the public key in the output and I think
Taj already talked about this when he
was talking about Bitcoin addresses so
the script pub key is instructions on
how to verify a signature of a public
key that has been hashed and the script
sig is that signature and the actual
public key the preimage of the hash
public key and this is what that looks
like so this is literally the script pub
key for a paid a pub key hash input or
output and this is literally the script
sig that would you would use to redeem
that output so this right here would go
inside one of these and it would set the
conditions under which you could redeem
this output and this right here would go
inside the input of the transaction
that's redeeming it and let's take a
look at how this actually works okay so
what the Bitcoin script interpreter does
is when it's evaluating whether or not a
transaction is valid it takes a look at
the input and it looks at which previous
transaction it's looking at and which
index the output is and it grabs the
script pub key well first of all and
make sure that output hasn't already
been spent then it grabs the script pub
key and it takes the script sig and it
puts them on top of each other just like
this so that's the script steak up there
this is a script pub key down here and
it runs this combined script through of
the Bitcoin script interpreter which is
based on a stack model so it starts
pushing things on to the stack it starts
at the very top and it starts pushing
these items onto the stack and
evaluating them and so the rules are
that constants get pushed onto the stack
and then operations and these things
right here are operations op do pop hash
160 people verify and op check sig these
are all Bitcoin op codes operations have
different rules as to how they're
evaluated and what they consume off of
the stack so the first thing is a
signature we're gonna pop the signature
and push it onto the stack because it is
a it is a constant so this would be the
signature that Alice might produce in
order to spend her output then same
thing with the pub key because the pub
key is also a constant then we're gonna
take this first like now okay we're done
with constants for the moment and the
next thing on the stack is op do op Duke
does basically exactly what it sounds
like it takes the thing that's currently
on the top of the stack and it
duplicates it so the way that we consume
up do is we take this pub key and we
create another copy of the pub key the
next up is op hash 160 also does exactly
what it sounds like
it takes what's on the top of the stack
it hashes it and it pushes that hash
onto the top of the stack so after we
run op hash 160 this is what our hash
will this is what our stack will look
like next thing is a constant so we take
that constant which is a it which should
be which is the hash of the pub key so
this is the address that this money is
being sent to essentially and we put
that on the top of the stack and then we
run this operation called op equal
verify whenever an op code ends with
verify it means that it's a little bit
special it means that it has the ability
to
if it fails break out of the entire
script execution and immediately cause
transaction validation to fail so op
equal verified does what it sounds like
it checks to make sure that the two
things on the top of the stack are equal
and if they're not equal then it
immediately fails validation so you'll
note that what the two things at the top
of this let's go back to what the two
things on the top of the stack are right
now okay so we pushed the cig we pushed
a pub key we duplicated that pub key and
these are from the script sig so this is
from whoever's redeeming the transaction
okay so whoever's redeeming the
transaction has put a copy of this of
this pub key on there and now that pub
keys on the stack twice we hashed the
pub key and then we put we pushed the
hash that was specified in the part of
the transact and the previous
transaction that set up the rules for
how to spend this okay and then op equal
verify make sure that these things are
actually the same and if they're not the
same then it'll fail that verify check
in the entire transaction validation
will abort and it's an invalid
transaction so let's assume that they're
the same okay great then op equal verify
can't then we continue transaction
validation and now we're left with this
op check sig pub key SiC and this does
exactly what you think it might do it
pops two things off the stack checks to
make sure that the signature is a valid
signature for this pub key and if it is
it pushes true on to the stack and if
there is a true on top of the stack in
fact I think it's if there's any
constant on top of the stack when we've
consumed all of the parts of our script
say again script pub key then this
transaction this returns true and we in
the veldt and the transaction is
considered valid
so let's this is a lot and and I know
this is kind of complicated so let's
sort of step through this one more time
and there's just a couple
things that I want to make clear this
part right here is set up in the output
of whatever transaction we're spending
so if Alice creates this transaction and
she's spending to Bob then Alice would
put whose pub key here hash of a pub key
actually right so Alice would put the
hash of bob's cup key here and it when
Bob's redeeming what would go in the
input that needs to redeem that output
sorry I can't hear Bob's signature and
the pub key that corresponds to that
signature because all we have is a hash
so those are the things that would get
put on top of the stack so up there we
have Bob signature and we have Bob's pub
key again those get pushed onto the
stack because they're constants
duplicated hash the top copy over the
hash make sure that they're equal and
then check the signature and this is a
paid a pub key hash script it is the
most common script in Bitcoin and this
is this basically the standard way of
spending money are there questions about
this yes
yeah that's a great question so um let's
say that we didn't have this equal
verify here then what could a malicious
spender possibly do that's a good
question I don't think that would matter
I'm not sure would it matter it's faster
to verify the two hashes are equal the
checks take operation takes a yes yes
every single node on the network is
running the Bitcoin script interpreter
inside of it and the Bitcoin script
interpreter is known as is what's called
consensus critical so if two nodes have
slightly different script interpreters
that would interpret this in different
ways the network would have a consensus
failure yes peanut booking is a thing
actually and paid aha punky hash is
considered better and the reason for
that is kind of subtle actually it's
because um so the hash of the pub key is
smaller than the pub key right and this
is definitely going on the blockchain we
don't know if this is gonna go on the
blockchain or not not all outputs are
consumed so let's put the small stuff
here and the big stuff over here it's
about saving space also the set of
unspent transaction outputs is something
that every node has to maintain it's
very important you are referring to it
quite a bit this is not something that
every node has to maintain and so you
you want to make this smaller even at
the expense of making this bigger yes
public events crew doesn't actually
verify could you accidentally sign a
transaction that has a public keep of
script that doesn't verify let me see if
this answers your question so here is an
example of an unspent about put okay
the unspin double output has an
opportune as the first instruction of
its script pub key opera turn does what
you might think it does which means when
you evaluate it
it returns immediately and says invalid
and so if you have one of these in your
transaction in your script pub key
there's no script cig that could
possibly redeem the script pub key you
could create a anything you wanted and
no matter what you put on there would
never be it would never evaluate to true
there's no way to actually redeem the
script pump key in this output does that
answer your question okay
well that's the next slide so yes this
is what's called an anyone can spend
output okay the simplest anyone can
spend output is just an empty script
pucky because a script sig that has op
true in it would evaluate to true notice
here there's no public keys there's no
signatures
there's no hashes of public keys the
script pub key doesn't actually specify
any public keys and so but when you
evaluate this right here you push up
true on to the stack and then you would
finish and there would be a true up true
would push sorry off true would push a
true on to the sack and then when you
finish there would be a true on the
stack meaning this is valid yep yeah so
um so this is an anyone can spend output
and this is a no one can spend output
and yeah there's no public keys in here
there's no signatures in there so you
can totally create outputs that have
nothing to do with signatures or maybe
have you develop verify multiple
signatures which we're not gonna go into
right now but it's also possible
yes yes yes yes again there are fewer
than 200 opcodes the number of standard
op codes is even smaller meaning that
there's a very small number that you can
use in your scripts and script pub keys
and it it's definitely possible if you
write some weird script pub key or some
weird script cig to accidentally create
outputs that are never spendable or to
accidentally create outputs that could
be spent by someone else so there's a
standard set of script pub keys to use
and I would not recommend going outside
that set except for in the lab that
you're gonna do because we have some
more fun ones in there
yes sure Pena's script cash I don't
actually have slides on peda script cash
so I'm not sure that we can do a good
job of explaining it right now but the
idea behind peda script hash is that
yeah I don't have I don't have the the
slides for it but the idea is that
you're going to put instead of instead
of this particular script pub key here
you're gonna have a script pub key that
includes a hash of a script and then the
script sig has to produce that script
you know and it has to match that hash
and the whole thing has to verify it's
the rough idea behind peda script cache
and I can we can produce an example of
that for you tomorrow but the cool thing
about that is you don't even know what
you have to do to redeem this output
right so someone has to produce a script
that when combined that has the same
hash and when combined with the script
pub key will evaluate to true yeah so so
um the script sig and the script pub he
literally just get concatenated together
and then evaluated is one thing so yeah
it would it would just go through the
same thing question any more questions
so what do you guys think is this good
is this bad
yeah that's a great question so the
question is could you Dawson network by
creating transactions that are not
spendable you can't really daus the
network per se so um so this is an
example of a transaction that's not
expendable and see how it has this opera
turn that says whatever there is this
pattern of people who like to store
things in the Bitcoin blockchain because
it's there and it's very highly
replicated and so one type of
transaction that a lot of people make is
an opportune with a hash of some data in
it or some data in it these are unspun
double outputs that will live on the
Bitcoin blockchain forever and will be
part of the you TXO set possibly forever
generally Bitcoin developers discourage
using Bitcoin in this way because it
does bloat the you TXO set that said
there's nothing to prevent you from
doing it if you want to pay the fees you
know that okay things I didn't know that
they weren't kept in the UT access it
okay I didn't know that those weren't
included in the UT Exocet so that's good
so then it doesn't block the UT Exocet
it just goes in the blockchain and you
paid the feet put your transaction in
the blockchain so good for you yes
that's a great question so why have this
weird opcode thing right I mean what
kind of sense does this make so the
problem with a general programming
language is it's really easy to shoot
yourself in the foot it's really easy to
write a program that you think you know
how many of you have had a bug in your
program ever please all of you should
probably raise their hands right so and
how many of you have had bugs in your
program that showed up a lot later than
you thought they would when you thought
your program didn't have any bugs right
so these things once you put them out
there
these script cookies and script once you
put these transactions out there they're
out there you cannot take them back
well not easily ah and you know they
might execute in ways that you didn't
anticipate them executing the more
complicated the script you write the
more likely it is that there's some hole
in your script some way of satisfying it
that you didn't anticipate that could
end up stealing your money right so with
a general programming language rule you
might think oh well at least you know
these op codes are super tricky and
weird and I don't understand them at
least with the general programming
language I'm more likely to write
correct things right
you know actually having the strange
opcode language has a lot of benefits so
number one it's not turing-complete
you know exactly how much CPU is it is
going to take to run these scripts
because of because of the nature of the
opcodes and the language you you there's
no for loops in here you know you can't
just run a while that takes forever
these the this is a stack based language
and so it's very easy to tell how long a
transaction is actually gonna take to
execute and this is really important
because every node in the network has to
execute these things so you don't want a
script sneaking in there that's going to
you know take hours to execute it's also
you can look at the number of op codes
in the script and
like I said get a rough sense of how
expensive it's gonna be and that's why
there are limits on the number of
opcodes you can have in a script it's
very difficult to do that if you have a
more general programming language so
those are a couple of reasons and I mean
I think it's important to point out that
aetherium which does have a more general
programming language they're constantly
problems popping up where people are
taking advantage of transit of contracts
even fairly well understood ones are so
called you know we thought they were
well understood and figuring out how to
freeze people's funds or steal people's
funds so that's the motivation behind
this sort of strange language are there
any other questions I don't understand
them right now and I do want to stress
when you're dealing with real money so
not in the lab for this class you want
to stick with very standard scripts you
don't want to write super crazy weird
tricky scripts or if you do you want to
get them vetted very carefully
yes great question so the there are two
levels at which things can be enabled or
disabled in Bitcoin so first there's the
validation rules so what makes a
transaction valid or not valid right and
that meaning that if a transaction is
invalid and it's in a block that whole
block is invalid if a transaction is
invalid and in a block and that block is
in a block chain that entire block chain
is invalid so there's there's that level
and we're going to talk about sort of
how those rules change and who sets
those rules but you can consider them
sort of for now being set by the the
code the Bitcoin core or the Bitcoin
software which specifies what is valid
and what is invalid
but there's another level at which you
can you can you can sort of adjust what
is what sort of ends up getting accepted
or not accepted and that is what is
transmitted over the peer-to-peer
network so there are transactions that
are valid but are what's known as non
standard and that transaction if it gets
into a block that block is still valid
but the nodes in the network if it sees
that transaction won't relay them around
so you'd have to like be a minor and
actually decide I want this transaction
in a block and mine that block and if
you do that everyone will consider it a
valid block okay fine but no one will
actually send your transaction around
and so the you know if you're not a
money or yourself the odds of it getting
into the blockchain are very low and so
those are the two sets of rules the
peer-to-peer rules are more restrictive
than the validation rules okay so we
already kind of started talking about
this a little bit you know what are the
benefits of UTX those and what are the
downsides of UT exo's so one of the
benefits of UT exo's is that but you
guys see how they help with with replay
attacks I can sure I can copy this
transaction and put multiple out there
but you're only allowed to spend an
output once and once you consume that
output that's it so you can't really do
replay attacks in this model so it's a
very sort of elegant way of getting rid
of the replay attack problem without
having to store a nonce per account in
your system another benefit is that you
know you can actually get a little bit
better privacy with this UT EXO system
because you don't have to use the same
public key for all of your transactions
you can generate new ones every single
time and then combine ut EXO's from
different things into I mean you're
gonna have to combine them anyway even
if they did spend at the same public key
so why not generate fresh ones all the
time and it becomes a little bit harder
to track who you're spending and who
you're paying to and the account based
model you need to have you know it's
more likely that all of your funds are
gonna be in one account in order to make
a spend now Adele
of UT EXO's is that they're complicated
so when I first heard about UT EXO's and
I first understood how Bitcoin worked I
was like why does Bitcoin work this way
this makes zero sense an account based
model would be so much easier and I mean
I think for wallet providers and for for
people who are writing user software it
is easier to deal with an account based
model than a UT EXO model because people
who are writing Bitcoin wallets software
have to keep track of all of your UT X
OS and then figure out how to combine
them to get the amount that you want to
spend and make sure that they produce
what are called change outputs the right
way so you don't like accidentally lose
some of your money because you're
spending an output that has a hundred
Bitcoin but you're only paying someone
one Bitcoin you better make sure you
have that 99 Bitcoin output in there
going back to you right so it just makes
everything a little bit more complicated
you can't you know you can't just spend
the amount you want to spend you have to
find these outputs and combine them in
the right way and and and figure all of
this stuff out another problem is around
fungibility so this is why I say that
bitcoins not fungible because of these
outputs and the fact that you have to
point back to the output that you're
going to spend which ends up creating
what's called a transaction graph so you
can sort of see how things are chained
together and you can actually discern
quite a bit of information about what's
going on in the network and in fact the
FBI has used the transaction graph in
some of its cases around Silk Road to
see where Bitcoin was moving and there
are many companies out there chain
analysis elliptic that provides services
based around the fact that bitcoins
transaction graph is totally open and so
you can you can sort of see how coins
are moving around so in addition to the
transaction graph problem you kind of
lose this aspect of fungibility in the
sense that let's say that I know that
for whatever reason these coins came
from let's say like I don't know a
terrorist or something like that you
then know exactly where those coins are
going and you can kind of see the chain
of transaction
that come off of those coins and it sort
of creates a potential opportunity for
someone to blacklist coins or you might
decide that you know you like coins that
were produced that are that are fresher
than other coins so there's this ability
to distinguish between coins which is a
little bit troublesome because
fungibility is is generally considered a
very good property for money to have and
this is not entirely functional but
people are working on that
any other questions I alluded to this
earlier but every single node that's
running the Bitcoin software keeps this
data structure called the UT Exocet so
these are all of the outstanding unspent
transaction outputs it's all the coins
in the system all the money in the
system that's available to be spent the
way that this is computed is when a
Bitcoin node comes online and starts to
download the blockchain they run through
the blockchain and continuously add and
remove things from the UT Exocet to
produce a UT Exocet that is valid for
whatever the last block is that it's
seen when a new block comes in node runs
through the block and again removes and
adds things to the UT exocet as
necessary right now there's about I know
60 million UT X OS in the UT Exocet a
lot of them unfortunately well a lot a
lot bye sigh look by like in terms of
bytes of the UT Exocet a lot of them are
very small and are unlikely to get spent
very soon so that's kind of a bummer the
you take so said is about three
gigabytes right now I think and so every
node in Bitcoin in addition to storing
the blockchain stores this UT Exocet and
uses the state structure to very quickly
tell if a transaction is a double spend
or not any questions about the UT X I
said yesterday
that's a good question how do you avoid
having small transactions accumulate
over time I don't know the answer to
that question it's kind of a bummer
the it's not really in people's interest
to generate those transactions because
you're creating I haven't talked about
how fees are computed yet but fees are
measured according to the resources that
a transaction takes up in the system
during fees are measured according to
the size of the transaction so if you
have to combine a whole bunch of tiny
outputs in order to get a big enough sum
you're gonna have to pay more in fees so
it's not really in your interest to
produce a lot of these tiny things but
there's not really a good way of
stopping it and in fact there have been
services in the past like Satoshi dice
and whatnot that have created a ton of
very tiny outputs and uploaded the UTX
is that I don't know Taj if you have any
insight onto how to stop that from
happening other than the fees other than
the fees yeah yes
[Music]
yeah
so I'm not sure in the account B's model
we'll find out more about this when we
get to the etherium section of the class
how you combine spending from different
accounts but but Bitcoin makes it very
easy to combine spending from different
pub keys and the account based model I
could imagine it being a slightly more
complicated process but that's a good
point yes you could definitely create a
lot of accounts with a lot of small
balance but if you want to spend a lot
you're gonna have to somehow accumulate
all of that spending remember I talked
about how there is like one special
transaction in every block called the
coinbase transaction and this
transaction does not have to follow all
of the rules specified before so this is
kind of like a hard coded exception into
how Bitcoin works that there can be this
one transaction in every block called
the coinbase transaction it is the first
transaction the coinbase transaction has
exactly one input and that input needs
to have certain field this input does
not point to a previous output ok this
input is essentially empty this is the
transaction that doles out the block
reward so this is the transaction that
the block reward used to be 50 Bitcoin
25 bitcoins 50 bitcoins now it's 12.5
bitcoins per block this is the
transaction that doles out that 12.5
bitcoins plus the fees of the block so
it has exactly one input and that input
has all zeros for the previous
transaction ID and then ffff for the
index into that previous transaction ID
I think the script sig can basically be
whatever you want it's not evaluated it
might have to be valid I'm not sure and
then its output is in satoshis so this
is 12.5 Bitcoin because remember a
Bitcoin is 10 to the 8th satoshis so
this is 12.5 Bitcoin plus here are the
fees from that block and you probably if
you're the one so the miner is the one
who creates this
action and the miner who creates this
transaction probably wants to give
themselves the Bitcoin and the block
award and so would specify in here a
script pub key that they could redeem
note that this also has the nice
property of making well I don't know if
it's a nice property but all the blocks
that people work on are actually
different because each book in each
block the coinbase transaction is going
to be different because each person's
trying to pay themselves for the
different miners yes great question so
um what would happen if a miner put like
100 bitcoins in there any idea so what's
keeping that at 12.5 bitcoins is the
same thing that's keeping invalid
transactions out of the blockchain which
is the consensus rules of Bitcoin it
says in the code that at this point in
time given the block height where we are
that number should be no larger than
12.5 plus the fees in the transaction
and if a miner put a different number in
there a higher they can put a lower
number that's fine they'll end up
burning some Bitcoin which is
unfortunate but if they try to put
something higher in there the network
will regard it as invalid because the
network is running a set of rules and we
are in this class going to get to what
happens when you want to change that set
of rules which gets really tricky but
right now assume that the network is
running the set of rules they're all
checking they're all validating and so
the answer is the network would reject
this block if there was a higher number
in there so this is kind of fun because
you can sort of put whatever you want in
here
and so miners like to put advertisements
in there and there actually was a pit
there was like a time I don't know if
you can still do this where you could
literally buy the space from miners and
put whatever you wanted in there so you
could put your name
or you know like ask someone to marry
you or whatever you know you might want
to do to put in the Bitcoin blockchain
for all eternity but yeah so so miners
like to put fun things in the script zig
and maybe we could we could show them
some of those things later or you could
go look yourself
[Music]